en el vídeo anterior vimos que la
presión en un fluido es la presión es
igual a raw o la densidad por la altura
por la gravedad
veamos cómo usar esto para resolver un
típico problema de física digamos que yo
tengo aquí un tazón
que tiene mercurio vamos a dibujarlo en
un tono gris e citó
esta estación tiene mercurio
y además tengo un tubo de ensayo
invertido más o menos así
y no hay aire dentro del tubo aquí es
está vacío vacío
aunque todo lo demás se encuentra
rodeado de nuestra atmósfera a nivel del
mar por lo que la presión atmosférica va
a estar empujando
a este tazón
aquí tenemos
atmósfera
depresión y al no haber aire en el tubo
de ensayo este mercurio va a subir
por lo que este mercurio va a empezar a
subir aquí
mercurio del que está acá va a empezar a
subir en el tubo
de hecho este es el principio del
barómetro que mide la presión mi
pregunta aquí es qué tan alto va a subir
el mercurio
en el tubo de ensayo
entendamos aquí que aunque no los
sintamos porque ya estamos acostumbrados
a ello tenemos todo el peso de la
atmósfera sobre nosotros y sobre el
tazón y lo que se encuentre dentro del
tazón y ya que dentro del tubo de ensayo
no hay presión el mercurio va a subir
bueno antes de resolver el problema hay
un par de cosas que debemos saber
antes que nada debemos saber que la
gravedad específica del mercurio
gravedad
la verdad específica
y la específica
del mercurio
mercurio
13.6
y 13.6 el término de gravedad específica
se refiere a la razón entre que tan
denso es un objeto o una sustancia con
respecto al agua eso significa que el
mercurio
que el mercurio mercurio
es
3.6 veces
más denso más denso que el agua
más denso que el agua y yo espero que
del vídeo anterior ustedes hayan
recordado cuál es la densidad del agua
la densidad del agua es de 1000
kilogramos por metro cúbico por lo que
la densidad del mercurio
es igual a 13.6 la densidad específica
por la densidad del agua que es de 1000
kilogramos sobre metro cúbico y
realizando el problema queremos saber
qué tan alta es esta columna de mercurio
que subió por el tubo de ensayo la
presión en la base de la columna de
mercurio hacia abajo debería ser la
misma que la presión hacia arriba pues
el mercurio no se está moviendo está en
estado estático y así algunos videos
atrás aprendimos que en un sistema de
líquidos la presión de entrada es igual
a la presión de salida vamos a dibujarlo
aquí la presión hacia abajo debe ser
igual a la presión
hacia arriba porque esto los estamos
viendo y si tengo una atmósfera que va a
estar presionando hacia abajo pues voy a
tener una atmósfera
una atmósfera
más feroz
que va a estar presionando hacia arriba
así que dentro del tubo de ensayo
tenemos estos elementos estas fuerzas
que están trabajando
así que la fórmula
de la densidad por la altura por la
gravedad va a ser igual a una atmósfera
vamos a escribirlo en un color verde
citó
está mi presión es igual a una atmósfera
esto es igual a la densidad por la
altura hay que ser que quiera estar
este símbolo este por la altura por la
gravedad
esto es igual
la densidad
esto es
13 mil 600 kilogramos por metro cúbico
esto lo sustituimos aquí 13 mil 600
kilogramos por metro cúbico aquí si
escribo las unidades nunca perdemos de
vista que debemos verificar que las
unidades y las operaciones que estamos
haciendo sean correctas
esto por la altura la altura nuestra
incógnita la voy a poner en otro color
en amarillo
x
la gravedad que la gravedad sabemos que
es de 9.8 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado
y esto es igual a 1
lo que queremos saber es la h por lo que
vamos a despejar esta h
pero bueno que es una atmósfera aquí hay
otro dato que es importante memorizar lo
voy a notar por acá una atmósfera una
atmósfera
es igual aproximadamente porque bueno no
es totalmente homogénea la atmósfera en
toda la tierra
101 mil
300 pascales o lo que es lo mismo esto
es aproximadamente igual
103 mil
newtons sobre metro cuadrado vamos a
reescribir todo esto ya con los valores
adecuados
y tenemos entonces
13 mil 600 kilogramos sobre metro cúbico
bueno por la altura la altura es nuestra
incógnita seguimos marcando aquí en otro
color
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado es
igual
este segundo parece un 8 permítanme
borrarlo y escribirlo mejor
segundo al cuadrado es igual a 101 1300
newtons sobre metros al cuadrado uso
esta porque las unidades que estoy
ocupando me va a ser más fácil poder
trabajar con ellas por este valor
si yo despejo h
h va a ser igual
esto que está multiplicando a la h aquí
lo voy a pasar dividiendo esta cantidad
por lo que me va a quedar 101 1300
newton sobre metro al cuadrado
/
13 mil 600 kilogramos sobre metro cúbico
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado y
aquí siempre hay que asegurarse de tener
las unidades correctas ahora hagamos los
cálculos voy a hacer un poco más de
espacio aquí para poder mostrar los
cálculos
y nos va a quedar que h es igual
101 1300
/
13.600 por 9.81
lo hacemos en la calculadora
para que no quiere duda alguna entonces
vamos a dividir 101 1300 entre
abrimos paréntesis 13.600
y 9.81 cerramos paréntesis
y nos queda
0.75 9 que podemos redondear loa 0.76
h va a ser igual o la altura
es igual a 0 punto 76 metros que es
aproximadamente igual a 77 centímetros
y con esta medida respondemos a la
pregunta inicial de cuál es la altura
que obtuvo el mercurio al subir por ese
tubo al vacío
esta altura es igual a aproximadamente
77 centímetros y también podríamos hacer
una marca aquí de que esto vale una
atmósfera y tener así un barómetro